CBS News senior national security
contributor Michael Morell is a former
deputy director of the CIA Michael good
morning good morning one point on David
reporting is it possible that this was
also to send a message to North Korea I
don't think the u.s. intended it that
way I think it was used because there
was a military purpose I do think it
might be seen by Kim Jong Il as a
message what are the capabilities of
North Korea as we speak they have
nuclear weapons they've tested nuclear
weapons five times a number of times
successfully they have short-range and
medium-range ballistic missiles that are
capable of reaching their targets they
have deployed an ICBM that's capable of
reaching the continental United States
they beyond being an Internet capable of
reaching the continental United States
that they've never tested and we think
they've had enough time to mate a
nuclear weapon to a missile so the
threat is now right it's not two years
from now or five years so they can reach
this now now we have to assume that yes
and so the threat to us of them had in
nuclear weapons is what beyond reaching
us now so it's use right it's use
against South Korea Japan against us its
sale to another country and it's loose
nukes in a situation where the regime
collapses and who controls those nuclear
weapons there's three different threats
where where's our help here it's China
of assistance the president has been
talking to she didn't ping and yet at
the same time it appears that that
relationship is more complicated than
the president previously understood so
if you're going to squeeze North Korea
economically China has to do it because
China is 80% of their trade but there's
there's there's two issues here one is
China's willingness to squeeze them
China fears an unstable nuclear-armed
North Korea more than they fear a
nuclear-armed North Korea they don't
want to bring about instability the
Chinese keep on making that point and
then the second issue is even if they
did squeeze them their ability even if
they did squeeze them with North Korean
behavior change I doubt it
the North Koreans tend to do something
provocative around this birthday
celebration of their founder this
weekend what else what are we expecting
here
so I would expect based on everything
we're hearing a nuclear test it is
possible there could be a missile test
to go along with the nuclear test why do
you think this crisis is happening now
beyond this ban aversion I think that's
a really good question
I think there's two issues one is we
have a new president and Kim jong-un is
trying to challenge him is trying to get
him back to the negotiating table
remember Barack Obama ignored the North
Koreans for eight years did not run to
the negotiating table every time there
was a provocation Kim jong-un wants to
get back to a situation where we give
them gifts when they do something bad
and then we are also making it worse
right with our bluster and by sending
aircraft carriers in there we're raising
the crisis it's best to just ignore this
guy and to deter him from ever using
these weapons or selling them and to
build our defenses so on that note you
say that Kim jong-un may look at the
deployment of this so-called mother of
all bombs as a sort of demonstration of
US military might it sounds like that
bomb was first moved into Afghanistan by
the Obama administration how long has it
been in the works so this is this has
been so so we've used bombs like this
before both in Vietnam and in
Afghanistan
nothing ever this big but it's but it's
as David said as David Martin said it's
designed to deal with these cave
complexes and that's where these Isis
guys have been hiding so it has been
there for a while approved for use this
is not some new strategy on the part of
a battlefield commander general
Nicholson who could make the decision
without having to take a sit the
Pentagon yes yes and there's a balance
here there's a really important balance
here between killing Isis on the
battlefield in Afghanistan and then
driving driving people to extremists so
we had former President Karzai overnight
and criticizing the use of this weapon
for that very reason so there you need
to strike a balance I'm not saying this
was the wrong thing to do but there is a
downside to using it all right Michael
Morell thanks very much